I know something you don't know.
Oh, yeah?
What's that?
You are absolutely going to be
what's best for her.
Writing and publishing this book
was a long journey.
I actually came up with the idea
all the way back in 2003.
I was really interested
in the Enron trial.
I am telling you, Owen
is not that guy.
You’re starting to sound
like most wives
whose husbands have been
accused of white-collar crime.
I started to imagine a woman
who found herself between who
she thought her husband was,
and who the world thought he was.
And in 2016,
after I gave birth
to my first child,
I was able to find the story
I was hoping to tell.
You know, I was a little like
you when I was your age.
Which is about someone
becoming a mother.
And that's the book that
we are turning into
this wonderful series.
So where is he, Hannah?
Where's my dad?
He's going to have an
explanation, you know he will.
The Last Thing He Told Me,
people will be thrilled with
if they're fans of the book.
Laura Dave has thought
through every possible choice.
She knows what she wants
to put on the screen.
My husband, Josh,
and I knew that we wanted
to write the show together.
And the beauty of
a television show
is that you can be expansive
and spend more time
with these characters,
and up the propulsion
of what’s happening to them.
Like all of Laura's great fiction,
not only is there a great drive,
there's also this real heart
underneath it.
The best television
operates on multiple levels,
and I think this does that.
I may not know why your
father did what he did,
but I know who he is.
I love Laura Dave's writing.
It's not very often that I feel
I have to do something.
I just have to do it.
I wrote letters to everyone
involved about why
I would really love the
opportunity to play Hannah Hall.
The letter brought tears to my eyes.
She connected so
wholeheartedly to this character,
and we really knew
she was meant to play her.
Have you seen a teenage girl?
Sixteen, blond, pink streaks.
Writing the book, Hannah
was sort of amorphous in my mind.
Now, when I reread the book,
it's Jen's face, and it
will always be Jen's face.
She is Hannah Hall to me.
What could you possibly
say right now
that would make any sense?
I don't know.
He lied to me.
He lied to me, too.
Even for people who have read it,
we are trying to
hone Laura's incredible
book into something
vivid and alive,
but also surprising.
When I read her book, I was just amazed
how tight the story is.
We want to show to be
the same kind of thing
where you go, “I got
to see the next episode.”
Everyone just really
brought their A-game,
bringing the show together
in a way that
it's beyond my wildest dreams.
You said that people don't
run for no reason.
Hannah, you need to
get out of there now.
I thought that part of
my life was over.